I first did a little bit of boxing in
the fall of nineteen ninety-two I I my
first novel had been out for three years
but is really struggling to write a
second novel and I went back to school I
moved to New York and went to Columbia
University and I took this three-day
seminar with the writer Richard Price
and and he said a few things to me that
were very important I told him I was
struggling to write a second book and he
had talked about how he had struggled to
ride a second or third book and he had
forced one out and he realized he should
never do that but he had been under the
mindset that good dog when published bad
dog were not published and so he wanted
to be a good dog but wrote a book just
to publish a book and that's the state
of mind I'd been in for three years and
he went on in the seminar and then
private conversation I'll mix the two
but he said I realized that I could only
write about something I loved and then
when you write a book you have to be in
love and then he also said writers hang
out you know and I had after he must
have said that in the class and I
followed him down the street you know
Broadway after the class and I said I
totally identify with what you said good
dog bad dog and you know I'm really
struggling to write a second book and he
said are you into cops and I said well
sort of my father had been an auxiliary
policeman and because what had turned
around Richard Price is writing career
was he for like a movie assignment or
something he went and hung out with cops
in jersey city and he just loved the
dialogue and their stories and this is
where the he fell in love with this end
he was hanging out these two principles
be in love and hang out so he gave me
the number of a detective in jersey city
that I could call whom I could possibly
hang out with and I didn't call the guy
but I was like all right I've got to
hang out I've got to find things i'm in
love with and i realized i'd always
loved boxing so i found a gym in in
Times Square area back when they were
boxing gyms still in Times Square and
peep shows and I started boxing
and i also realized i had a fascination
i translate the word love as fascination
obsessed by haunted by with transsexuals
so i would box at kingsway boxing gym on
40th an eighth avenue and then i would
walk up three blocks to 43rd between
eighth and seventh and go to this
transsexual bar called Sally's and I was
in these two very different worlds and
eventually I stopped boxing and just was
going to Sally's and then found
something else that I was in love with
which was this mad older roommate I had
moved in with and that became the bait
all that world of going to Sally's
living with this older gentleman as a
roommate that became the basis for my
second novel the extra man so the first
little bit of boxing 1992
much of Times Square I mean I mean I
don't think little of it I mean it's a
spectacle when you go there at night
with all the lights and it certainly is
very cleaned up I mean I was of two
minds back when it was much more
hardcore on one hand I've always been
drawn to the gutter and so I liked that
whole CD world on the other hand you
know as a New Yorker I did feel I think
some embarrassment for the tourists that
would come to Times Square and
forty-second Street the center of the
city and it was just you know sex and
people Hawking things and now I guess
it's the same thing but just very glossy
I don't know not very sexy though but a
lot of Hawking but the lights are
spectacular and so that's a spectacle
boxing um I I like to test myself I like
to take risks I also I i think i would
like to be free and adventurous but it's
very hard to be free in life and but the
boxing ring is this chance to be a hero
or you know to to engage in probably
primal aspects of the mind and the body
that you wouldn't tap into and and and
there's a lot of myth and romance you
know coming through those ropes you know
be like getting to play center field for
the Yankees you know so I think for me
it's a lot of the metaphors of it the
romance of it the chance to test myself
to test my courage at the same time it
hurts a lot I don't necessarily want to
hurt anyone else you know though I like
the idea as in any sport to see how you
can score you know it's not very good
left hook but I'm limited here with the
camera but so those aspects of it I
don't like and the part of hurting your
brain or hurting someone else's brain is
not pleasant
my greatest moment in boxing was and I'm
the rankest of rank amateurs you know so
my great moment is not like I am a
wonderful practitioner of you know the
Queensbury rules I had two bizarre
amateur fights so I'll know of no great
boxer but my greatest moment was at the
end of my second fight that I had
survived and that I hadn't gotten hurt
and that I had one you know but yeah I
hadn't humiliated my opponent and but it
was it was just a good match and just to
survive it's so hard to be in the ring
you get so exhausted you're so
frightened and I was injured going into
it my jaw was all out of line I was
really concerned that i was going to
mess up my John why am I doing this I'm
a writer I don't think I had health
insurance at the time you know what am i
doing putting myself at such risk but so
to have survived was glorious and it was
over and I didn't have to train anymore
and I didn't have this pressure of that
it was going to go into a match and
maybe be injured and my girl friend rose
up to the ropes you know we had this
kiss after the fight and it was
photographed but at the moment it was
just it was just very glorious and when
I stepped into the ring a lot of my fans
were there and I fight as the herring
wonder and the cheers I received was
really warm it was almost made me cry
actually it was kind of like all my
years of writing and performing in New
York I got a huge thank you and this
this you know the sound of the cheers as
I entered the ring
you